There's something undeniably entertaining
about watching actors mess up a scene by flubbing
a line, breaking character, or even walking
into a wall.
These classic movie bloopers are just as entertaining
as the films they came from — in fact, in
some cases, they're even better — and they've
kept us cracking up for years.
Smokey and the Bandit 2
More than 35 years after the release of Smokey
and the Bandit 2, many comedies still run
a blooper reel over the closing credits.
And from Bandits' credits, it's clear that
stars Burt Reynolds and Sally Field had a
blast working on the film.
“When do we get started?”
“That’s my line, you say ‘whenever you
like.’”
“Whenever you like.
It’s alright, keep it rolling, this is good
stuff.”
“Yeah, I like this."
Sadly, in the years since, a credits blooper
reel has actually become a pretty reliable
indicator that the movie itself isn't all
that funny.
“You’re wrong.”
Home Alone
Unless you're some kind of monster, there's
not much that's funny about watching a child
get hurt.
But when Macaulay Culkin slips on ice in an
outtake from the first Home Alone film...well,
it's downright hilarious.
“I thought the Murphys went to…”
Perhaps it's because falling down is always
funny — no matter who's doing the falling.
North by Northwest
In one of Alfred Hitchcock's best films, North
by Northwest, Eva Marie Saint's character
pulls out a gun in a crowded cafeteria.
As suspenseful as it is, viewers who pay close
attention will know ahead of time that she's
going to fire that gun.
That's all thanks to a little boy in the background
who plugs his ears five seconds too early.
“Just get back.”
“Why you little fool.”
“You just stay away from me.”
[Gunshot and screaming]
Back to the Future
In this classic time travel comedy, Michael
J. Fox's character, Marty, takes a swig from
a bottle of booze while on a date with Lorraine,
played by Lea Thompson.
To his surprise, some Back to the Future associates
decided to help him out...by filling it with
actual liquor.
[Laughter]
His reaction was 100% real...and he didn't
seem too upset about it, either.
The Frighteners
Before he moved on to epic films like The
Lord of the Rings and King Kong, Peter Jackson
directed this quirky horror movie about a
guy who develops the ability to communicate
with ghosts.
Though Michael J. Fox wanted audiences to
associate him with something other than Back
to the Future, it seems that even he had a
hard time doing that himself.
During the shoot, when speaking to the character
named "The Judge," Fox kept calling him "Doc"
— as in "Doc Brown" from Back to the Future.
“Little cook in the Pony Express, huh Doc?
Whoa!
I called him Doc.
It's f---ing Back to the Future."
“Doc!
Doc, I did it again.
Wrong f---in’ movie."
We're the Millers
Jason Sudeikis Jennifer Aniston, Emma Roberts,
and Will Poulter pretend to be a family as
part of a drug smuggling operation in We're
the Millers.
In one scene, Sudeikis's character turns on
a radio, and TLC's "Waterfalls" is supposed
to play.
Instead, the cast and crew took this opportunity
to prank Aniston — by blasting the theme
from Friends instead.
“I love this song!”
“Woo!”
Aniston's emotional reaction made it totally
worth it.
“That was really good.”
Liar Liar
Jim Carrey is an incredible improviser, and
directors will often just keep the cameras
rolling and let him experiment.
Liar Liar is one of Carrey's most over-the-top
comedic performances, and while the filmmakers
couldn't use all of his hilarious improv in
the film, they created a gag reel to play
over the credits.
"Prenuptial agreements."
[Laughter]
It's also quite a treat to watch cast members
clap back at him with hilarious moments of
their own.
“Your honor, I object!"
“You would!”
“Over-actor!”
“Jazz-”
[Laughter]
Star Trek
One thing unites the many different Star Trek
properties, from the original series in the
1960s, to the world-expanding shows in the
'80s and '90s, to the big-budget film reboots
of the 21st century: Spaceship doors never
seem to work correctly.
“Sensors are configured-”
"Aw, c'mon!"
For generations, these characters just can't
seem to exit a room.
“Very-”
Raiders of the Lost Ark
The classic Indiana Jones flick Raiders of
the Lost Ark is a film with a mistake that
actually made it into the final cut — and
it's kind of a gross one, so of course we
can't look away.
In an extreme close-up on actor Paul Freeman,
the camera catches a fly landing on his face
and crawling right into his mouth.
"Your persistence surprises even me.
You’re gonna give mercenaries a bad name."
In an interview with fan-site The Indy Experience,
Freeman claimed that the fly never actually
went into his mouth, but that an editor played
around with frames to make it look like it
did.
The effect is gross enough that there's really
only one appropriate reaction:
[Screaming]
Meanwhile, another beloved movie has a blooper
that made its way into the final cut — and
is now as cherished a part of the movie as
any of its other parts.
Star Wars
Probably because it's part of one of the most
successful and beloved movies of all time,
the stormtrooper bonking his head on a doorframe
during Star Wars is one of the most famous
movie bloopers ever — and it never gets
old.
“Take over.”
It's a rare and welcome bit of physical comedy
in the otherwise dramatic space opera.
Plus, with stormtroopers constantly getting
themselves shot, blown up, and thrown around,
this minor mishap really helps drive home
the idea that these faceless soldiers are
the Imperial Keystone Cops of outer space.
"Huh?"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!